en el vídeo de energía de ionización
hablamos de agregar suficiente energía a
un átomo neutro para quitar un electrón
dejando atrás un guión positivamente
cargado así que esto representa a la
energía de ionización y ya que
necesitamos energía para quitar un
electrón de un núcleo positivamente
cargado nosotros representamos la
energía de ionización con un signo
positivo agregamos energía y nuestras
unidades son kilo jules por mol
en este y en el siguiente vídeo
hablaremos de agregar un electrón a un
átomo neutro y para la mayoría de los
átomos añadir un electrón a un átomo
neutro different energía para formar un
guión con carga negativa conocido como
añón y ya que este proceso libera
energía usualmente lo representaremos
con un signo negativo las unidades
seguirían siendo kilo tools
more
y esta es una manera de hablar de la
afinidad electrónica
esto representa a la afinidad
electrónica
para algunos átomos agregar un electrón
no libera energía
de hecho necesitas energía para forzar
al electrón a formar a la unión y eso es
porque el núcleo de algunos átomos no
tiene afinidad por un electrón y
entonces si quiere representar a la
energía para un caso como este
necesitaremos energía por lo que la
representaremos con un signo positivo
kilo yours formol positivos y ya que
esto es bastante difícil de medir la
mayoría de los libros de texto dirán que
la afinidad electrónica para estos
átomos es mayor a 0 o igual a 0
eso es lo que ves más aquí y entonces
si se libera energía como en este
ejemplo este electrón que estamos
añadiendo deberá tener atracción por
este núcleo y entonces así es como
pensaremos en la afinidad electrónica en
este vídeo sólo hablaremos de tres
elementos en el período dos hablamos del
litio el berilio y del boro hablaremos
más de la tendencia general en el
siguiente vídeo ahora analicemos al
litio
sabemos que el litio tiene un número
atómico de 3 hay 3 protones en el núcleo
y en un átomo neutro
sabemos que el número de electrones es
igual a ese número 3 electrones para el
litio dos de ellos están en el orbital 1
es aquí están nuestros dos electrones en
el orbital 1s y luego tenemos un
electrón en el orbital 2s
este es el electrón en el orbital 2s si
estamos añadiendo un electrón al litio
es el electrón quedará en el orbital 2s
continuaré agregando un electrón al
litio en magenta y esto ya no será 12 1
será 2 s 2 ahora tenemos dos electrones
en el orbital 12 y esto ya no será el
átomo neutro de litio será el avión del
litio aquí el litio con una carga
negativa analicemos a añadir ese
electrón al litio en términos de los
tres factores que discutimos en el
último vídeo en los vídeos de energía de
ionización hablamos de carga nuclear
porque sabemos que entre más positivo
sea el núcleo esa carga positiva atraerá
con mayor fuerza al electrón que tiene
carga negativa
este electrón en magenta está cargado
negativamente cargas opuestas se atraen
de acuerdo con la ley de coulón y
entonces esa carga positiva de +3 va a
atraer a ese electrón de carga negativa
así es como podemos pensar en la fuerza
de atracción entre esas cargas opuestas
pensemos en otros factores
tenemos apantallamiento electrónico y la
idea de el apantallamiento electrónico
era que los electrones de los orbitales
más cercanos al núcleo estos electrones
en el orbital 1s van a repeler a este
electrón más alejado van a blindar lo
del efecto completo de esa carga
positiva de 3 en el núcleo estos dos
conceptos juntos la carga nuclear y el
apantallamiento electrónico te darán la
carga nuclear efectiva y entonces el
electrón el magenta no siempre la carga
de más 3 en su totalidad debido a la
pantalla miento
de esos electrones más cercanos al
núcleo y después hablamos por último de
la distancia la distancia del electrón
que agregamos desde el núcleo hasta el
orbital 12 s / menor sea esa distancia
será mayor la fuerza de atracción que es
electrón sentirá por el núcleo y
entonces cuando sumas todos estos
factores que acabamos de discutir
resulta que es enérgicamente favorable
agregar un electrón al átomo neutro de
litio y se liberan 60 kilos jules por
mol de energía cuando esto ocurre
y entonces la fuerza de atracción del
núcleo generalmente hay una fuerza de
atracción del núcleo para ese electrón
por lo que el litio tiene afinidad por
él así que libera energía cuando le
agregas un electrón ese es el concepto
de afinidad electrónica aquí hagamos lo
mismo para el siguiente elemento veamos
al berilio ahora nos movimos un número
atómico hacia arriba ahora tenemos el
número atómico 4 4 protones en nuestro
núcleo luego tenemos 4 electrones y dos
de esos electrones están en el orbital 1
s
aquí están dos electrones en el orbital
1s y luego dos de esos electrones están
en el orbital 2s aquí tenemos nuestros
dos electrones en el orbital 12 s
obviamente estos dibujos no son
perfectos están muy simplificados para
ayudarnos a entender estos conceptos si
quisiéramos añadir un electrón al átomo
neutro del veril yo no lo podríamos
añadir al orbital 2s porque está lleno
por lo que tendríamos que abrir un nuevo
suv orbital aquí deberíamos de agregar
ese electrón a un orbital 2 p por lo que
la configuración electrónica sería 2
tendríamos que agregar un electrón al
psuv orbital 2 p aquí está nuestro
electrón y magenta añadiéndose a nuestro
orbital 2 p así que éste ya no será el
berilio neutro será el berilio con una
carga negativa
pensemos en esos tres factores que
acabamos de discutir primero la carga
nuclear es electrón en carga negativa va
a sentir una fuerza de atracción del
núcleo y esta carga es mayor a la de
litio ahora tenemos más cuatro pensando
sólo en la carga nuclear por sí sola hay
un incremento en la fuerza de atracción
del núcleo para ese electrón sin embargo
también tenemos otros efectos en los que
pensar debemos pensar en el
apantallamiento electrónico este
electrón en magenta es apantallado por
estos electrones más cercanos al núcleo
igual que en el litio sin embargo con el
berilio tenemos estos dos electrones en
el orbital
y ya que añadimos el orbital en magenta
un orbital 2 p el electrón en el orbital
2 p está en promedio más alejado del
núcleo y entonces estos electrones en el
orbital 12 se pueden hacer un poco de
apantallamiento electrónico cierto están
en promedio más cercanos al núcleo y
entonces apantallar an a ese electrón en
magenta de esa carga completa positiva
de 4 en el núcleo hay un poco más de
apantallamiento que en el ejemplo
anterior con el litio y finalmente
pensamos en la distancia la distancia a
este electrón en magenta desde el núcleo
es en promedio más grande que en el
ejemplo de litio del electrón que
agregamos en el litio
y ya que está más lejos hay menos fuerza
de atracción así que aunque tengamos un
incremento en la carga nuclear tenemos
un mayor apantallamiento electrónico y
el electrón que tenemos está un poco más
alejado del núcleo y resulta que cuando
ves los valores de afinidad electrónica
de hecho se requiere energía para añadir
un electrón al átomo neutro de el
berilio así que el anón de berilio es
inestable una manera de pensar en esto
es que añadir un electrón al orbital 2p
abrir un nuevo sub nivel significa que
es electrón está más alejado del núcleo
y entonces el núcleo no deberá tener
suficiente carga positiva para atraer
ese electrón en el último orbital que
añadimos y esa es la razón para el hecho
de que el berilio no tiene afinidad por
un electrón aquí deberá tener una carga
extra para atraer a ese electrón
eficazmente
y esto es parecido a lo que vemos con el
boro aquí vemos al boro ahora
incrementamos a un número atómico de 5
tenemos 5 cargas positivas en el núcleo
y vemos la configuración electrónica
para el gorro
2 electrones en el orbital 1 s 2
electrones en el orbital 12 s y un
electrón en el orbital 2 p este electrón
en el orbital p aunque esté en promedio
más alejado del núcleo aumentamos la
carga positiva en nuestro núcleo ahora
es de más 5 y esa carga positiva extra
es suficiente para mantener a ese último
electrón hablamos de afinidad
electrónica estamos agregando un
electrón a ese átomo neutro y entonces
si agregamos un electrón al boro este ya
no será 2 b 1 será 2 p 2 estaríamos
agregando un electrón a un orbital 2 p
así que continuaremos añadiendo a ese
electrón aquí de esta manera
y ese ya no será el átomo neutro del
boro será el boro con una carga negativa
una vez más pensemos en nuestros
factores
y entonces primero tenemos a la carga
nuclear cierto este electrón que
añadimos en magenta sentirá una fuerza
de atracción debido al núcleo y
nuevamente pensando únicamente en la
magnitud el incremento en la carga de +5
significa que el electrón será atraído
con una fuerza un poco mayor si piensas
en el apantallamiento electrónico
nuevamente tenemos una situación similar
al electrón anterior cierto tenemos
apantallamiento de estos dos electrones
de orbitales internos y ya que agregamos
a este electrón al orbital p eso está en
promedio un poco más alejado que el
orbital 12 s así que podríamos tener un
poco de apantallamiento electrónico de
esos electrones en el orbital 2s y
entonces tenemos un caso aquí donde
tenemos un apantallamiento electrónico
similar pero un incremento en carga
nuclear por lo que la carga nuclear
efectiva que es electrón en magenta
siente ha aumentado
también tenemos que pensar en la
distancia esta distancia de aquí
esto está en promedio es electrón que
agregamos en magenta estará
prácticamente a la misma distancia que
el electrón en magenta que añadimos en
el veril así que la distancia no genera
un efecto diferente ya que tenemos un
incremento en la carga nuclear efectiva
en esta situación el electrón en magenta
sentirá una fuerza de atracción mayor
por lo que el boro tiene un incremento
en la afinidad electrónica comparado con
el veril y podemos ver eso reflejado en
el valor aquí menos 27 kilos por mol la
energía de hecho se libera cuando añades
un electrón al átomo neutral del boro y
entonces finalmente comparemos al litio
con el boro tanto el litio como el boro
liberaron energía cuando les añades un
electrón pero de hecho vimos que el
litio libero más energía el litio tiene
una mayor afinidad por ese electrón y
podemos explicar eso otra vez en
términos de hacia donde va
para el átomo neutro del litio añadimos
a ese electrón a un orbital 2s
déjame continuar cambiando de colores
para ver eso añadimos es electrón al
orbital 27 aquí aquí está el electrón
que añadimos para el boro añadimos ese
electrón a un orbital 2 de este electrón
de aquí el electrón que añadimos al
orbital 12 en el litio esté a la
izquierda es el electrón tiene un poco
menos de apantallamiento electrónico y
está más cerca del núcleo así que al no
estar tan apantallado y estar más cerca
del núcleo tiene una atracción mayor del
núcleo positivamente cargado y entonces
esta es sólo una manera de explicar esa
pequeña diferencia en la energía
el por qué el litio de hecho tiene una
mayor afinidad electrónica que el boro
en el siguiente vídeo cubriremos el
resto de los elementos en el segundo
período hablaremos del carbono del
nitrógeno del oxígeno del flúor y del
neón